what i'd like to do in this video is get
an intuitive sense for what the
derivative with respect to x of sine of
x is and what the derivative with
respect to x of cosine of x is and i've
graphed y is equal to cosine of x in
blue and y is equal to sine of x in red
we're not going to prove what the
derivatives are but we're going to know
what they are and get an intuitive sense
and in future videos we'll actually do a
proof
so let's start with sine of x so the
derivative can be viewed as the slope of
the tangent line so for example at this
point right over here it looks like the
slope of our tangent line
should be zero
so our derivative function should be
zero
at that x value
similarly
over here it looks like the derivative
is zero the slope of the tangent line
would be zero so whatever our derivative
function is at that x value it should be
equal to zero
if we look right over here on sine of x
it looks like the slope of the tangent
line would be pretty close to 1.
if that is the case then in our
derivative function when x is equal to 0
that derivative function should be equal
to one
similarly over here it looks like the
slope of the tangent line is negative
one
which tells us that the derivative
function should be hitting the value of
negative one at that x value
so you're probably seeing something
interesting emerge
everywhere
while we're trying to plot the slope of
the tangent line it seems to coincide
with y is equal to cosine of x
and it is indeed the case that the
derivative of sine of x is equal to
cosine of x and you can see that it
makes sense not just at the points we
tried but even in the trends if you look
at sine of x here the slope is one but
then it becomes less and less and less
positive all the way until it becomes
zero cosine of x the value of the
function is one and it becomes less and
less positive all the way until it
equals zero and you could keep doing
that type of analysis to feel good about
it in another video we're going to prove
this more rigorously
so now let's think about cosine of x
so cosine of x right over here the slope
of the tangent line
looks like it is zero
and so its derivative function needs to
be zero at that point so hey maybe it's
sine of x let's keep trying this
so over here
cosine of x
it looks like the slope of the tangent
line is negative one
and so we would want the derivative to
go through
that point right over there all right
this is starting to seem it doesn't seem
like the derivative of cosine of x could
be sine of x in fact this is the
opposite of what sine of x is doing sine
of x is at one not negative one at that
point
but that's an interesting theory maybe
the derivative of cosine of x is
negative sine of x so let's plot that
so this does seem to coincide the
derivative of cosine of x here looks
like negative 1 the slope of the tangent
line and negative sine of
this x value is negative 1.
over here the derivative of cosine of x
looks like it is 0 and negative sine of
x is indeed 0. so it actually turns out
that it is the case that the derivative
of cosine of x is
negative sine of x
so these are really good to know these
are kind of fundamental trigonometric
derivatives to know we'll be able to
derive other things for them and
hopefully this video gives you a good
intuitive sense of why this is true and
in future videos we will prove it
rigorously